[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein leckeres Mittagessen.
Eigentlich wollte ich ja nur Smashed Potatoes machen,
also
zerdrückte Kartoffeln.
Bei uns artet das Ganze aber beim Mittagessen,
muss ich sagen, immer aus,
weil uns dann noch die Idee kommt
und noch Gemüse
und da noch einen Salat.
Deswegen gibt es heute
– und das ist echt cool –
ein komplettes Menü.
Und das könnt ihr dann auch mal
für zwei oder drei Tage vorbereiten und dann essen.
Denn wir haben wirklich ganz viele verschiedene Bestandteile
und jeder aus dem Team und aus der Familie
kann sich einfach das nehmen, was er möchte.
Gut, Murat und die Kinder, die müssen natürlich
immer Gemüse dazu nehmen.
Aber beim Murat achte ich dann drauf,
dass der Fleischkonsum wegfällt
oder sogar gering gehalten wird
und eben so viel Gemüse wie möglich.
Und das sind wirklich Dinge
– ihr könnt das dann als Bowl anrichten
und das ist halt schon gut.
Ich habe jetzt hier zum einen
die Zutaten für die Smashed Potatoes.
Dafür habe ich jetzt Kartoffeln,
relativ kleine, muss ich sagen.
Und da achtet da am besten gar nicht darauf,
ob es vorwiegend festkochende oder mehlige sind,
sondern einfach, dass es eine gute, leckere Sorte ist.
Da könnt ihr einfach zum Bauern eures Vertrauens.
Und ich habe die jetzt schon gewaschen,
sodass wir die einfach direkt mit Schale verzehren können.
Dafür brauche ich dann noch Olivenöl und Butter,
Knoblauch natürlich
und, was ich vergessen habe,
– warte, ich komme gleich –
Petersilie.
So.
Dann habe ich hier ein Roastbeef
mit Rosmarin
und Butterschmalz.
Hier habe ich die Gemüsepfanne.
Dafür nehme ich Brokkoli,
Champignons,
rote Zwiebeln
und Bohnen aus der Dose.
Hier mache ich noch meinen Salat.
Da habe ich hier jetzt
frischen Blattspinat,
– das ist so Babyspinat –
Frühlingszwiebeln,
rote Zwiebeln
und Rucola.
Und dann gibt es noch eine Sour Cream dazu
aus Schmand beziehungsweise saurer Sahne,
etwas Quark oder Joghurt.
Und dann habe ich noch Knoblauch, Minze,
Salz und Pfeffer.
So.
Ich zeige euch die Zutaten jetzt so im Groben.
Denn ihr könnt im Prinzip
auch bei der Gemüsepfanne einfach alles verwerten,
was ihr noch im Kühlschrank habt.
So machen wir es auch immer.
Alles in die Pfanne und fertig.
Das Erste, was ihr machen solltet:
Die Kartoffeln, die eben bereits gewaschen sind,
auf ein Backblech geben.
Und
das Öl mache ich später drauf.
Die kommen jetzt erst mal in den Backofen
und dürfen schön weich garen.
Und in der Zwischenzeit bereite ich alles andere vor.
Und später ist dann alles zeitgleich fertig.
[Musik]
Dann habe ich hier so ein kleines Pfännchen.
Und da gebe ich die Butter rein.
Dann etwas Olivenöl für den Geschmack,
aber auch dafür, dass die Butter
in der Pfanne später nicht zu schnell braun wird.
Ein bisschen mehr.
Das ist ja für die Kartoffeln.
Und jetzt den Knoblauch fein hacken
oder in Scheiben schneiden.
Ich habe jetzt übrigens endlich das Problem gelöst
mit dem stinkenden Schneidebrett.
Ich habe jetzt eine Seite,
die ist für Zwiebeln und Knoblauch und Herzhaftes,
– das ist die Murat-Seite –
und eine Seite, das ist die süße
für Obst und Desserts.
Und die stinkt dann eben nicht nach Zwiebeln.
Das ist die Sally-Seite.
So. Hier jetzt die Knoblauchzehe fein hacken.
[Musik]
Das kommt jetzt hier mit rein
und ich kann es jetzt einfach schon mal zur Seite stellen.
Das brauche ich später, wenn die Kartoffeln fertig sind.
Aber dann ist es schon mal bereit.
Dann kann ich ja als Nächstes die Gemüsepfanne vorbereiten.
Das bedeutet, ich habe zum einen
einen großen Bräter hier
und kann die Zwiebeln schon mal schneiden und reinlegen.
Aber, wie gesagt, ich schalte es jetzt noch nicht an.
Denn das mache ich später,
wenn die Kartoffeln dann fertig sind.
Jetzt wird erst mal alles vorbereitet.
Die Zwiebeln so in Halbringe.
[Musik]
Jetzt auch schon mal Olivenöl dazu gießen.
Es muss gar nicht so viel sein.
Dann kann ich das Gemüse putzen.
Das habe ich alles schon gewaschen.
Und hier beim Brokkoli,
ich meine, die Röschen, das wisst ihr, benutzen wir sowieso.
Beim Brokkoli aber auch den Stängel mit benutzen.
Also ich schneide hier unten das Holzige weg
und schäle den Rest
und kann das dann einfach fein gewürfelt dazu geben.
Dann muss man das nicht wegschmeißen.
Oder direkt aufnaschen.
So hat es meine Mama immer gemacht.
[Musik]
Und die gebe ich jetzt hier in ein großes Gefäß.
Denn später werde ich zuerst die Zwiebeln anbraten
und das Restgemüse dann zum Schluss dazu geben,
dass es schön knackig bleibt.
Also im Prinzip ist auch beim Kochen
gerade, wenn man so viel gleichzeitig macht,
eigentlich die Vorbereitung so das Wichtigste,
dass man sich alles vorbereitet
und nicht jetzt sofort anfängt, alles anzubraten,
sondern erst mal alles schneiden und schnippeln,
so, wie es halt zeitlich passt
und eben auch zeitlich sinnvoll ist.
Und dann ist man später gut fertig.
Dann kann ich jetzt schon mal das Fleisch anbraten.
Das mache ich jetzt hier im Bräter.
Der passt auch gut in den Backofen.
Da spare ich dann ein bisschen Geschirr.
Denn ich werde jetzt das Fleisch
erst mal hier anbraten für Röstaromen
und dann im Backofen fertig garen.
So. Und deswegen habe ich jetzt hier Butterschmalz.
Schön heiß werden lassen,
also schön scharf, heiß anbraten von allen Seiten.
Und beim Roastbeef
oder bei Fleisch allgemein darauf achten:
Nicht das Fleisch aus dem Kühlschrank nehmen
und dann in die heiße Pfanne legen.
Dann wird es echt zäh,
weil es einfach so einen Hitzeschock bekommt.
Deswegen legt es lieber
eine halbe Stunde, Stunde früher raus,
damit es so ein bisschen akklimatisieren kann.
Und dann kann es fast zimmerwarm
in die heiße Pfanne gegeben werden.
So.
[Musik]
Ich lege jetzt hier direkt den Rosmarin dazu
und gare das, wie gesagt, im Backofen fertig.
Ich mache das jetzt mit Thermometer.
Da, muss ich auch sagen, bin ich ganz glücklich,
denn ich habe hier so ein Backofenthermometer
mit drei Messpunkten.
Denn gerade bei so einem Roastbeef
habt ihr ja auch ganz viele Fettschichten mit drin.
Das ist ja schön marmoriert.
Und wenn jetzt hier nur ein Fühler dran wäre,
wäre es ja so
– und ich genau ausgerechnet diese Fettschicht treffe,
dann messe ich ja nicht die Temperatur des Fleisches,
sondern die des Fettes.
Deswegen sind hier drei Punkte.
Und immer erst, wenn alle drei die gleiche Temperatur haben
– denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist nicht groß,
dass man dreimal Fett trifft.
Und wenn alle drei die gleiche Temperatur haben,
könnt ihr das Fleisch wirklich auf den Punkt perfekt garen.
Wir wollen es natürlich rosa.
Ich muss jetzt hier gucken.
Ich weiß, hier dazwischen ist es so ein bisschen geteilt.
Das ist so das kleinere Stück,
hier das größere.
Deswegen würde ich es jetzt einfach mal hier reinstechen.
So.
Und dann im Backofen garen.
Wenn ihr jetzt kein Backofenthermometer habt,
es gibt ja auch
– oder nicht am Backofen direkt,
es gibt ja auch einzelne Thermometer.
Die sind auch recht günstig.
Die könnt ihr dann auch reinstecken.
Oder einfach bei niedriger Temperatur,
bei 100°C etwa,
je nachdem, wie dick das Fleisch ist,
so zwischen
– eigentlich kann man keine große Angabe machen,
wenn man nicht weiß, wie groß das Fleisch ist,
aber so zwischen 20 und 30 Minuten.
Achtet aber lieber darauf.
Es kann auch etwas früher schon fertig sein.
Da muss ich sagen, Thermometer rein und fertig.
Ich mache mir das Leben einfach.
[Musik]
Wenn ihr auch einen Bosch Serie 8 habt,
könnt ihr auch hier direkt auf die "Assist"-Funktion gehen,
auf "Fleisch",
"Rindfleisch"
und könnt jetzt hier "Roastbeef englisch" ,
"Roastbeef medium".
Englisch wäre natürlich sehr rot.
Medium wäre so, wie wir es gerne essen.
Und dann kann man es gerne hier auch noch anpassen.
Also ich kann jetzt auch hier mit der Hitze noch weiter runter,
mit der Kerntemperatur auch noch spielen.
Aber, wenn ihr Kenner seid,
könnt ihr natürlich auch hier
das Ganze manuell einstellen
– oder wenn ihr eben
keinen Assist-Funktionsbackofen habt.
Ich gehe nämlich gern mit der Hitze ein bisschen weiter runter,
damit es langsamer geht,
und mit der Kerntemperatur ungefähr auf 56°C.
Hier sehe ich gerade,
das hat 30°C Kerntemperatur momentan
und ich möchte auf die 56°C,
und sehe auch hier, wie lange ich jetzt noch Zeit habe,
um das restliche Essen vorzubereiten.
[Musik]
Die Kartoffeln sind jetzt gar
und dürfen noch ein bisschen nachziehen.
Das Fleisch ist auch schon
– es hat noch so 10°C ungefähr.
Bei den Kartoffeln übrigens darauf achten:
Die vorher einstechen.
Denn mir ist hier auch einfach eine im Backofen explodiert,
hat eine Sauerei gemacht.
Also vorher mit einer Gabel oder mit dem Messer einstechen.
Jetzt kann ich hier die Zwiebeln anbraten.
Hier habe ich jetzt auch das Pfännchen
mit dem Knoblauch und dem Olivenöl und der Butter.
Und wenn die Zwiebeln dann schon
so ein bisschen Röstaroma haben,
einfach das restliche Gemüse dazu geben.
Wie gesagt, nehmt, was ihr einfach im Kühlschrank habt.
Und das brate ich jetzt schön mit,
aber lasse es schön bissfest.
Also ich mag das Gemüse immer gern,
wenn man noch Biss hat.
Und dann könnt ihr es mit Salz und Pfeffer würzen
und mit Kräutern, die ihr gerne habt.
So.
Und hier der Knoblauch auch,
bis er ein bisschen Röstaromen hat.
Und im Prinzip kann ich jetzt hier schon mal
die Sour Cream machen.
Dafür den Knoblauch pressen.
Da könnt ihr den auch mit Schale lassen.
Den muss man vorher gar nicht schälen.
Und dann einfach nur mit allem verrühren.
Und da gucke ich auch immer,
was ich im Kühlschrank so übrig habe,
vielleicht auch was Offenes.
Joghurt, Schmand, Quark,
alles, was ihr habt, einfach verrühren,
mit Salz und Pfeffer würzen.
Hier habe ich noch die Minze aus dem Garten.
Die habe ich getrocknet.
Und dann ist die fertig.
Wenn euch ein bisschen Säure fehlt,
könnt ihr auch ein bisschen Essig noch dazu geben.
Oh, ich habe sie noch gar nicht gewürzt.
>> JOSH: Ein bisschen Salz.
>> SALLY: Ein Kilo Salz.
Es sieht immer nach so viel aus. Ich weiß.
Ja, wie gesagt, wenn ein bisschen Säure fehlt,
einfach Essig dazu geben.
Dann ist das fertig.
Und dann kann ich hier noch
die roten Zwiebeln und die Frühlingszwiebeln schneiden
und gleich noch ein Salatdressing machen.
[Musik]
Heute haben wir gar nichts Rotes dabei.
Heute sind wir so auf Grün.
Aber ich muss auch sagen,
dass ich auch Rotkohlsalat sehr liebe.
Und den haben wir auch oft dabei.
Karotten mag ich auch sehr gerne.
Aber das war jetzt halt heute so unsere Resteverwertung,
eine grüne Bowl
mit roten Zwiebeln.
[Musik]
Dann kann ich hier jetzt
den Salat hier dazu geben
– den lasse ich jetzt einfach so –
und ein Dressing anrühren.
Das mache ich jetzt hier mit Olivenöl,
mit Granatapfelsirup
und Essig.
Und ich gebe noch Sumak dazu.
Das ist Essigbaumgewürz.
Das hat auch so einen säuerlichen Geschmack,
mag ich ganz gern bei Kartoffelsalat
oder bei rotem Zwiebelsalat.
Das kommt noch mit rein
und Salz und Pfeffer,
wobei Pfeffer nur ganz, ganz, ganz wenig.
Ich mag es nicht so, wenn der Salat so zu pfeffrig schmeckt.
Dafür umso mehr Salz.
Es sieht nur immer nach so viel aus.
Mein Gott!
[Josh lacht]
Lach mich doch nicht immer aus mit meinem Salat
– mit meinem Salz.
Okay.
Das steht bereit.
Salat ist fertig.
Hier gebe ich noch die Bohnen zum Gemüse,
dass die auch noch ein bisschen rösten.
Und dann kann ich das Gemüse auch würzen
mit Salz und Pfeffer
und, wenn ihr möchtet, mit weiteren Gewürzen.
Aha, das Fleisch ist auch fertig.
Guckt. Alles wird gleichzeitig fertig.
Ich würze die Pfanne hier jetzt noch
mit ein bisschen Koriandersamen
und Thymian,
Salz und Pfeffer, klar.
Und die Kartoffeln hier sind jetzt auch gar.
Und jetzt könnt ihr die mit einem Glas zerdrücken
oder eine Burgerpresse nehmen.
Ich mache das jetzt hier mal mit dem Zerstampfer,
mit dem Whacker.
Guckt mal. Dann platzen die so ein bisschen auf.
Smashed Potatoes.
Gut, die eine ist ja sowieso explodiert.
Und da kommt jetzt die Knoblauchbutter rein.
Und was kommt noch drauf, Josh?
Und was kommt noch drauf?
>> JOSH: Salz und Pfeffer.
>> SALLY: Salz und Pfeffer.
[Musik]
Ja, das Problem ist:
Wenn ich Hunger habe, salze ich viel.
>> JOSH: Ja, ist ja okay.
Das ist so dein Ding. Bloß...
Also...
>> SALLY: Auf dem Fleisch fehlt übrigens auch noch Salz.
So.
Nicht zu viel, ja?
Gut!
Und jetzt habe ich das Gemüse fertig,
die Kartoffeln fertig,
das Fleisch fertig.
Das muss noch ein bisschen ruhen, bevor ich es anschneide.
Den Salat werde ich mit dem Dressing verrühren,
dann das Fleisch aufschneiden
und alles servieren.
Fertig.
Perfekt!
[Musik]
Also ich richte jetzt hier mal den Teller an.
Aber, wie gesagt, wenn wir jetzt hier alle zusammen essen,
wir packen alles auf den Tisch
und jeder füllt sich seinen Teller.
Und ich muss sagen,
das ist immer eine schöne bunte Mischung aus allem.
[Musik]
So. Eine Kartoffel nehme ich mir jetzt noch.
Und dann gibt es bei uns
– oh!
Noch den Dip dazu.
[Musik]
Dann gibt es bei uns jetzt Essen.
Und das Rezept gibt es wie immer
zum Nachlesen in meiner App oder auf sallys-blog.de.
Und dieses Gericht reicht uns jetzt für heute Mittag
für ungefähr vier bis fünf Personen
oder drei Frauen und einen Josh.
Und ansonsten,
wenn ich es jetzt mit Murat, Samira und Ela esse,
dann, denke ich, haben wir
auch noch ein bisschen was für morgen da.
Aber, wie gesagt, auch das Fleisch
kann man morgen noch schön kalt essen
und die anderen Bestandteile.
Dann haben wir morgen auch noch was zum Mittag.
Und, wie gesagt, eine tolle Resteverwertung eures Gemüses,
ein tolles Mittagessen oder Abendessen
und gut vorzubereiten.
Also viel Spaß beim Nachkochen!
Bis zum nächsten Mal! Tschüss!
[Musik]